[Music]
that's Prince Harry smiling as he
arrived in Victoria British Columbia on
Monday a source tells ET that the 35
year old is in Canada to reunite with
his wife Megan Markel and their eight
month old son Archie haven't seen Archie
omegan for nearly two weeks now Prince
Harry's really been left here to pick up
the pieces on his own he's absolutely
desperate to get back to his new home
Harry's arrival comes two days after his
grandmother Queen Elizabeth the second
announced that they'd reached a
resolution since Harry and Megan
announced they're taking a step back
from their royal responsibilities
according to a royal source the
discussions were all extremely friendly
and constructive because the common goal
was clear adding quote everyone is
pleased we all take a leap of faith so
thank you for getting to the courage to
take this next step a step that includes
Harry and Megan losing their royal
titles stepping back from royal duties
including official military appointments
and no longer receiving public funds for
royal duties there's been a lot of anger
from the British public over Frogmore
cottage the house that the Queen gifted
the couple for their wedding present but
which the taxpayer paid about 3.1
million dollars to refurbish but get
this the couple has agreed to repay the
money I think without a doubt Harry is
relieved this must have been a huge
weight on his shoulders
but I think there is a great sense of
sadness I think there's a great sense of
disappointment that he is leaving and
that he's had to give up some key role
what I want to make clear is we're not
walking away and we certainly aren't
walking away from you
for the first time since news broke
Harry spoke out publicly about his exit
from the royal family while at dinner on
Sunday for supporters of Santa bolli in
London the decision events I have made
for my wife and I to step back is not
one I made lightly
there was so many months of talks after
so many years of challenges and I know I
haven't always done it right but as far
as this goes there really was no other
option it was a very heartfelt speech it
was a very raw speech you could see that
that hurts that turmoil and it was very
interesting hearing Harry say that it
was his decision you know this has been
coined MEC sit over here in the UK
Meaghan Markel has been blamed for Harry
leaving his home country I think Harry
has been looking for a way out away for
a new life and Megan has simply been the
catalyst but make no mistake this was a
joint decision the Duke of Sussex made
one final appearance in London on Monday
attending the UK Africa Investment
Summit where he met with leaders from
Malawi Mozambique and Morocco to discuss
investment in renewable energy jobs
tourism and environmental issues
that evening Prince William alongside a
dazzling Kate Middleton hosted a
reception for the summit on behalf of
the Queen Harry was at this summit this
morning
William said tonight there'll be no
crossing over I think the severity of
what's happened has had a huge impact on
his brother on his sister-in-law I think
both of them are still reeling from the
news coming to terms with the reality of
of this situation and it seems Harry's
stepmom Duchess Camilla of Cornwall is
still coming to terms with Harry and
Megan's exit as well check out her
reaction when asked about the couple
during a royal engagement over the
weekend that face we can't but Megan's
besties Serena Williams had the best
response when asked about this Sussex is
in her post match interview at the
Australian Open yeah I am I have
absolutely no comments on anything good
try
you did good thank you next and speaking
of what's next for Megan and Harry
they're on their way to becoming
financially independent which means it's
time to start earning some money there's
an interest with Netflix we understand
they're open to making a possible series
with the couple autobiographies
apparently are out as is a big sit-down
talk with either Oprah or Gayle King
[Music]